Cassandra what were you from version
where'd you grow up I grew up in Long
Island New York and you grew up with
both your parents no I didn't actually I
didn't cook for Long Island aiya
I was born in New York but I grew up in
Michigan my first the story needs to
tell about me my first memory was um
come to find out uh my dad married my
mom she was pregnant with another man's
kid so I'm technically the firstborn um
and she but I then the story goes my dad
is the Navy I he's a nuclear physicist
he was on nuclear submarines my mother
must have been beautiful the only thing
I've been told about or that was that
she she was stacked but he was he walked
away from a full scholarship to Notre
Dame anyway I guess when he got off
being away for a few months he came to
my mother's mother's house and with my
mom on his arm and my baby sister
Monique who's three months old his
parents already had my older sister Dana
and said mom she cheated on me and he
left and my mom kept me about a year and
a half later my grandparents said I was
dropped off on their doorstep in a dirty
diaper with a man's shirt on and no
shoes the milliner and we had steak for
dinner that night and four hours later
we had dessert I had something in my
mouth I had saved all my chewed up meat
because I said I wanted to eat later I
think that's a saddest [ __ ] story I
ever heard
but they would laugh about it and tell
it as a dinner table I felt like the odd
man out
Oh guilty yes I'm talking about you know
because I feel like I felt healthier
than talking about why feel guilty I
feel like our society covets a level of
attractiveness or slenderness and being
the middle child also my I got special
treatment from strangers and uh my dad
he married my stepmother when we were I
mean I was six and he married her
basically to take care of this problem
which was the three of us me and my two
sisters and moved us to Long Island I
remember
I was very angry at my grandparents
house and uh I kind of digress but after
I got there every day
my grandma would tell me your mom's not
coming back she doesn't love you and
when my dad would come home at
dinnertime I had to say that my mom
didn't love me and she wasn't coming
back and I refused to say it so I had to
go to bed without dinner and I would get
a spanking
we did this for about two years not
obviously not a good Alliance to have
she never did come back so I don't know
what was worse like the that screaming
for her in my head or the silence when I
forgot she existed because silence has a
sound too but when we moved to Long
Island Dana and Monique they they were
so traumatized because my dad's parents
were the only parents they had known and
I remember thinking to myself how lucky
I was that growling grandpa didn't love
me
because I know whether it was true or
not this doesn't matter that was my
feelings about it but I felt
[Music]
and I say am i saying too much no no
you're perfect
no I just wanted to look psycho but
because it just drives up whatever
you're gonna say so you you were saying
um I remember thinking that and my
little sister Monique started wetting
the bed and she would just wake up from
a nap and come down to the kitchen and
she be tears would just be streaming
down her eyes and she didn't even know
she was crying that was what my stepmom
started hitting us she would call us
disgusting she would withhold food as a
punishment so we would eat food out of
the trash some girl called liars and
thieves when she would catch us there's
a line from a song where he says the
reasons all have run away but the
feeling never did so that feeling of
being guilty and/or warranted but when
we were in Long Island about two weeks I
had a dream about a guardian angel and
his name was Michael and he said that I
wouldn't meet him again but that I had
other guardian angels and my job was to
take care of my two sisters and that bad
things were going to happen to me in my
life and he wanted to apologize for that
but said that God didn't create us to
make to make us love him so there were
certain things he could control on
certain things that he couldn't
it was very vivid I woke up my sister
and told her about it and oddly enough
one of the last things my mother ever
said to me was just remember Cassie God
shrink-wrapped your heart they can take
everything else and men will touch you
but God shall corrupt your heart so
ah
I don't know I um during that period of
time I didn't know my dad that well and
I wish I had but I remember my
stepmother went back to Michigan for a
couple days and my father was left to
care for us now he had me was 20 so I
can imagine it was a young man and he
would have been what 25 at this time but
we were playing on the floor with one of
the first times I really spent time with
him alone and I remember he pinched me
so hard that it left like a blood
blister and I'm felt so a friend it was
such a strange thing I'd it's a strange
story to tell but after that I kind of
stayed away from him we we got a hit
every day my stepmom and started having
her own kids and Dana and Monique or
increasingly called fat and ugly we
weren't allowed to go in the store with
her because we were she was too
beautiful to have children like us or as
old as us and when we moved back to
Michigan I try to I always say that I
and I'm not mad but I don't think about
it I won't think about it longer than
five seconds my two sisters they hate
and they hate beautifully they they're
they're married they have good lives
well their sister has two masters
degrees younger sister got accepted to
all these amazing colleges but it's a
daily thing where they speak about our
childhood and blame them singularly that
doesn't work for me I find it's hard to
sustain
if I think about it longer than 30
seconds I'm the rage is so intense I I
just I think I can't handle it you know
I was 13 and a half my dad was arrested
for child abuse against me specifically
and you know my stepmother had been the
she broke my older sister's nose four
times food was always withheld as a
punishment
I used to have to take my clothes off
before I left for school and when I came
back I mean she physically put her
fingers inside me to see if I had taken
it was bringing anything home like a
candy bar wrapper so my father took it
to trial that day he they estimated he
making him about 60 times with the
buckle end of a belt and then an hour
and a half of I he was still mad so he
did it another 50 times shattered my
tailbone that night my clothes scab to
me but I didn't cry until I collapsed on
the floor and said please don't hit me
again she's so embarrassing
and he said I'm gonna hit you like this
every day that you're grounded so I ran
away that night and I went to school for
the first time I were just cool the next
day I never missed a day school my
principal says you're not allowed to be
here he had called the police I was so
terrified he's gonna get in so much
trouble
they were gonna relinquish me to him but
a female teacher demanded a female
officer I didn't make a statement
I never told but the injury spoke for
themselves he took it to trial
the day of the trial he asked me to lie
for him the end of keeping me in the
house they sent me to live with my
grandfather who said I was a [ __ ] and
couldn't stay there and but the day of
the trial in the cafeteria the families
on one side mean him wrong the other and
he says how do I feel about destroying
everybody's life and that he was gonna
go to jail and I said how does it feel
to have your freedom in the hands of
somebody that you said was so worthless
um that's one of the things I'm most
proud of that I had there the
wherewithal to know to say that if I
ever feel bad I can remember that and I
did live for him
one thing though I had a severe
stuttering problem that started when I
was a lot of six years old very very bad
most people don't know this about me
really bad every word does it did it it
was incapacitating and when I had this
when they put me on the stand I couldn't
say my name I now as an adult I go by
Cassandra but I couldn't say Cassandra I
don't say Cassie and I was supposed to
state my full name for the court and the
judge was a female she said I can't
believe you're gonna put her through
this why didn't he just accept the plea
bargain but I didn't live for him and I
left the next day I've never been back
but after I left
I said I had a social worker okay say
her name
Janine McFarland sure she was so amazing
this is in Detroit you know and she
found me
Janine found me until I until I was 30
years old and she would send me a gift
I mean we're talking she she showed up
inside three carat diamond earrings and
a mink coat drummer saying is that very
unusual when I was 15 I was bullied
really bad in school really really bad
in fact I came to a point before the
trial where I stopped seeing colors I
was really scared I was left for dead in
the snow by two girls it put cigarettes
out on me I always say the quickest way
to settle me up is put me in a room with
fucked-up people the worst thing I don't
think of did you to say I was upset with
smoke cigarettes but I remember I grew
up in a good name on a good neighborhood
if you will but the kids from the wrong
side of the tracks their parents didn't
ask why is this girl here on a school
night but I I have no idea why I got so
so fortunate I knew there were drugs all
around but I didn't see I didn't see
them and I stayed away from them but
somebody's a trashy mother called
somebody's I love them somebody's girls
girl that I would
was with this boy and I had yet to even
get that far with with a boy but a group
of people came and three girls beat me
up and I took all my clothes put
cigarettes are on me when I came to they
said that the streets that way I knocked
on seven doors it was about 7:30 at
night or someone open the door
holy fifteen
and I just remember coming in at a
consciousness bleeding all over this
yeah it was a young couple all over the
bathroom and I kept saying I'm really
not white trash and then my dad was in
the doorway I said how did you know who
my dad was they said you told us after
they put me back in the house
no one was allowed to call me Cassie
everybody had to call me stupid I was no
longer a part of the family the hitting
stopped but it was but it was on it was
it was a war and Dana and Monique they
got it the worst Dana got it really bad
like being beat up I remember my parents
really ever went out but the Christmas
cookies story they went out during the
holidays once and never had house keys
when I allowed to open the fridge or
touch the television or the radio
nothing we didn't have keys to the house
because remember we were liars and
thieves we might be food so we're
waiting it in the garage we would come
home from school and on the girl on the
door to the garage leading into the
house is you's guys my stepmother would
use that word better get your story
straight there are 32 Christmas cookies
and then and when I when we got home
last night there were 22 somebody's
going to get it you better whoever did
it you know better step forth
Dana starts wailing when little girls
you know and I remember saying okay okay
almost like Ferris Bueller's Day Off
right I'll take the heat my stepmother
or that that Aerostar me
a van pulls up she doesn't ask who did
it she just gets out she grabs Dana by
the hair and kicks her in the kitchen
and started banging her head against a
stove I'm terrified and that's when I
realized it didn't have to do with the
Christmas cookies and she did was just
raged she wanted to take out on on
anyone I remember running to the phone
and saying I thought she was gonna kill
Dana I'm gonna call
my stepmother just grabbed the phone out
of my hand and hit me over the head with
it and said you're not calling anyone
that was a valuable lesson my two
sisters no one grows up wanting to be a
liar or a drug addicts or promiscuous
but I don't I've made it was I feel
fortunate I learned very early on that
the goal posts were constantly changing
and I I was taught how to be a good liar
I liken my stepmother - I got big ogre
and you could see when it would start
who was in the frigerator or we didn't
take out the trash if you went to the
bathroom or left number two you'd have
to go into the bathroom and stand there
until someone said who did it for hours
like I wanted to squash the toilet I
mean I don't know where this means I
haven't never revisited this but if you
lied to my stepmother then it would give
them the realism of the punch wouldn't
be as it wouldn't it wouldn't hurt us as
bad feel like look over there you know
she over confuse her host so um if you
recall I have a different father than my
older sister Dana there's a picture of
us even though we're almost dead my
older sister is almost exactly your
older and my little my almost exactly
your younger we all shared a room but in
this photograph I am up to Dana's
shoulder and she has her arm around me
Dana it was much larger than me but more
of a gentle soul and more fearful
anxiety-ridden I would say when and
Dinah would go for her and we see if
Tina hit her back we just weren't big
enough you know Donna
she'd be terrifying today but uh Oh was
I saying
yes after I lost after the trial I would
anyone ever go to Cote and I would sit
in the breezeway of this restaurant I
feel about a month a man gave me a roll
of Dimes had to call someone I looked in
the yellow pages from him I remembered
my mother's maiden name and I found her
sister who came and picked me up the
first thing she asked was what kind of
cigarettes do you smoke and I hadn't
really learned how to inhale but I just
looked down and she smoked Virginia
Slims I said I smoked those she said
what a coincidence and went and got me a
back there were drug addicts oh yeah
almost sixteen fifteen and a half she
his son he was twenty years older he was
my cousin I never met him but she put me
in his bedroom I thought she didn't know
but now I realized she put me in his
bedroom so he'd come home with the drugs
and it was you do as we do or you don't
stay here I mean it's hard to express
it's hard it's hard to draw a picture
but we had no furniture much like
crackheads my cousin was a gaffer so I
always slept on the floor
we had a spool as our coffee table and
director's chairs and then we had a
chalkboard to keep track of anybody
double toked this is pot being the SWAT
team coming to her house actually but
that first night that I was there on the
floor in his bedroom my cousin got out
of his bed and laid down next to me
behind me and
I said never I mean ah the Messiah dine
runs kiss a boy so
he took my choice to choose he didn't he
didn't do it that night he was as as far
as predators go he made it seem I lied
to myself as if I was a participant in
it
it changes things this is really hard
for me to talk about
and it's really scary
I guess oh it's create certain
proclivities in your life I'm not going
to explain what that means we can show
you some of of the word you don't talk
about I guess I just he took what he
took and I didn't want to be just
scented that bus stop like I survived
over being molested so I just told
myself some story but then I was off
with the races I became in politics
that's the automated eviction I smoke
pot every day for five years I'll tell
you what and like I said God was my only
friend so I I cried myself to sleep for
him maybe two years wanting to get out
and good Henry
sure sorry I okay I guess to be able I I
didn't tell my aunt I felt like the that
you know just to protect her
I hadn't smoked pot before and I
remember telling a girl next door ah
after two weeks of being there I can't
keep doing this you know come to find
out my aunt had taken my dad to court
and she was getting money from him she
never so much as bought me a pair of
underwear she at first she told me yeah
you're not going to school anymore
you're going to watch Dylan which is my
cousin's son who was seven
I once we got evicted from every place
so I went from an upscale neighborhood
to basically the Skid Row of Michigan we
ended up in Redford Union 8 mile um
there was a shower and I'm in the
downstairs in one of the places that we
rented it was an unfinished basement
I'll never forget this I came downstairs
and I hear my little cousin was 8 years
old
saying sobbing going why me God why me
in the shower I did a pre prior to her
pulling the eye of school.i
I did end up going to high school for
about three weeks at a place at high
school called Redford Union on 8 mile
yes where Eminem hails from and to to to
to events happened I ended up meeting
the cutest boy in school whose
girlfriend was on a family vacation but
no one thought to tell me and the
principal there he had me in his office
and he asked me to unbutton my shirt for
him and that stayed with me forever
for a number of reasons that wasn't in
my file anything about me about sexual
abuse how did he know that I wouldn't
tell how I from then on it felt like
everybody knew like I was wearing a
Scarlet Letter everybody knew that I was
being molested and
I this is only one of the few times my
life I've ever vocalized that uh allowed
myself to a very compartmentalized
person and I don't consider myself a
liar and if I ever do lie it's because
I'm I've probably lied to myself as well
but how could you've known I wouldn't
tell and did I comply yes I thought I
found power from it in a way I'm the
flip side the on the via downside was a
million miles deep but after I thought
like I had no choice so I made it I lied
to myself as if I did in the moment and
what I was telling myself was so dad you
said I was so worthless well guess what
I can make this person risk everything
so how worthless am i if I can bring
this person to their knees
whatever somebody thinks of that is
neither here nor there it is what it is
as far as then and I maybe only know
this now looking back but after um
Mauricio his girlfriend got back we were
living
of course renting a place a place made
of Kleenex and spit there was maybe 40
girls outside calling from my head
terrifying so no I never went back to
school after that but I did have one
friend tomorrow who worked at Taco Bell
shortly thereafter the SWAT team came
into our house
my cousin Dugan was selling pot out of
the house my aunt would send me with him
to the tip of Florida where we would
drive there and back in three days he
would put the bricks of marijuana above
the engine he would use a gat for his
blanket yeah so when the SWAT team came
in you know get down get down get down
his girlfriend tomorrow she was about
300 50 pounds and she worked to talk
about the police kept calling her the
big burrito she's like she wasn't gonna
get down but it took us all to jail and
then they proceeded to tell me that if I
didn't buy drugs from three people three
times with marked money I was going to
go to prison they had photographs of me
opening the door wow this is so
embarrassing
I when I was 13 when 13 and a half or
ninth grade first started you were
allowed to leave campus for school and
there was this man tied Caribbean
he was probably 36 years old but he
would hang out inside the pizza place
and some of my girlfriends knew him of
course the girls from the wrong side of
the tracks but he went I would run away
from home he would put me in a hotel
room but so when I had to buy these
drugs with marked money I bought drugs
from friends of his that weren't really
drug dealers and I really only bought
two times from one person shortly
thereafter time I run into Todd again he
takes me to a party and we started
playing quarterback around 7 o'clock by
8 I was extremely inebriated I was taken
upstairs and gang-raped when he came in
the bedroom they had me tied up he asked
me about his friend who whose house the
police came into and how it was right
after I asked him to sell me drugs and
then he walked out of the door
I remember I have coming in out of
reality and I was begging at Mustapha
maybe were eight or ten college guys one
of the boys sisters comes in and sees
this and he gets hysterical she puts me
in the shower and I was just ashamed to
be alive
I was ashamed I guess I was ashamed that
I was a shame for myself ashamed that I
was there I was a person
years later let me try to get this
succinct my aunt right
she was an executive secretary so as we
got evicted from all these places she
would get a job as an executive
secretary she was married eight times so
the gentleman that she had been with
previous they actually had a home that
was in town and country but he end up
leaving her for her best friend who
could still have children so she had
this wardrobe but I guess she was
telling her other men she works with her
she had a daughter and she knew the
assistants and maybe they would like to
go on a date with me I didn't quite
understand it I know it sounds like a
dichotomy I felt so blessed but raw
fooder Bob Ian takes me to a hotel room
and says I can't do this and I say do
what and he tells me how my heart is
insinuated fully that he could have sex
with me for the $800 that he gave her to
help us with our rent money
I don't even know what to think about
this now I've never repeated that my
voices I never heard those words and I
feel a stranger I guess I can't put
anything anywhere huh
Hey
I met one of these men I never did have
sex with any of these men and I've
locked out a lot of it to me it was just
a handful one of these men took me to
his friend's house in a place called
Bloomfield Hills which was the bel-air
of Michigan his friend had a hot tub
where everybody had to take their
clothes off
this person was married and owned the
company where my aunt was it was the
executive secretary so I guess he wanted
to see me naked but his friend his name
was Michael he was 31 years old nice
Jewish boy my size and me and him he
really liked me he was single and I like
to assume so yes if you could take me
out on a date so we started going up
I never said anything about was
happening at our house and he never
asked he I'm one of us I remember like
our third day he takes me to his home I
had never seen anything so beautiful my
mind Joe had grown up in a nice
neighborhood but I had been in two years
that I have been you know in the Skid
Row of Michigan and if you can imagine
driving down a Boulevard take here in
California for example in Los Angeles
imagine driving down Sunset Boulevard
imagine sunset and Alvarado
she's even not the best example but take
sunset all the way past the bel-air
hotel how everything is green and opens
up and we take that drive it's the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen in my
whole life it's so beautiful
I remembered that there was a world
again but he made me his special pasta
dish I guess in the broccoli he had made
a smiley face two eyes and a smile out
of broccoli but I just started eating
first thing and he was so offended and
hurt that I had it waited to see the
smile in the pasta this kind of me is
there's got to be some answer there on
that right but after dinner I take off
my clothes and trying to have sex with
him and he was really freaked out I
don't know why machinist but it was
significant because I just speaks to his
character like slow down that wasn't
what he wanted to do you know you know
so we didn't
mind you he was the first person that I
had tried to do that with since I was
gang-raped that I kind of going
backwards a bit but that morning when I
woke up with throw-up in my hair and I
was in the shower
I swear I would never have sex with
anyone again and I fought off my cousin
after that so things were coming to a
head a real head going back to Michael
he started taking me to hippy festivals
and he got me to drop acid with him
which I would never take back I would
never do it again but I would never take
that back I did every six or seven times
and it I've been told it bridges the
consciousness subconscious and my
experience I didn't see pink elephants
but I saw how beautiful the world was
and just how and just how the way I grew
up was just no way to live just and
there was something more that said I
know that Michael knew a lot more and he
never asked I never told but one day
after going to a wedding and we had been
drinking and the night before we had
taken I said I come home to get changed
for another events that were going to go
to and my cousin is at this point he's
now obsessed with me calling me a [ __ ]
and a slide of bimbo just going on every
day she was violent following me his
advances become very very violent try
me and I just walked out the door and
walked all the way to Michael's house
and he opens the door and he said you're
not gonna lie you're not leaving you're
here to stay right he just knew and I
said yes and we made a bowl of mashed
potatoes and we were so nervous we were
saddled like Haunter across legs and ate
the mashed potatoes and then we met him
across the street this there was this
beautiful school and there was a swing
set we sat on the swing set and the Sun
was setting and it was the most
beautiful day I'd ever seen I thought
this is the first day of my life no
one's ever gonna hit me again no one's
ever gonna touch me again I was ever
gonna call me a name it's over now it's
finally over I was when the greatest
moments of my life so I like to be
buried
so
how's my first home
and that lasted maybe two and a half
years so that's where I put smoking pot
like I said I cried myself to sleep for
two years I carried that addiction into
that relationship
my little sister called Monique Monique
so while when he was getting written up
in the newspaper and living at grandpa's
because remember I was a [ __ ] I
couldn't live at grandpa's I'm getting
raped violently at night but my cousin
when he calls me to tell me that she's
gotten into the AmeriCorps the
domesticated Peace Corps I say it when
will you come see you before you go away
she says
Cassie I have a life and it homes a
phone I looked around me and I thought
Todd doesn't exist
I've been talking to no one this whole
time
there's no one and I just panicked I had
my first panic attack
and uh I ended up at the hospital
well I started getting anxiety attacks
every single day I live at the hospital
they offered me a xanax and I had taken
at acid it was January the third next 97
but so New Year's Eve I had and I
thought this is an acid flashback this
is it you know I'm I'm [ __ ] for life I
went to floor therapist of course the
most expensive one I'm almost gonna
remember his name Stan stands on the
other he said are you hearing voices kid
I said no he said you feel like driving
in oncoming traffic
I said no he's like they're gonna be
fine the one before him said well I said
Michael Smith I just smoked pot previous
to hanging up the phone and I said to
her well Michael smokes the same pot too
because I mean where Billy was laced
with something she said well if you
drink from a carton of milk only one
person's gonna get to swallow with a
spider I remember calling her up later
telling her how irresponsible that
statement was the reason for a lot of my
worry was turns out my mother was a
paranoid schizophrenic but turns out
turns out that that's a diagnosis from
the state to get money so who really
knows if she was really a paranoid
schizophrenic and they can't test for
schizophrenia shows up between the ages
of 19 and 22 so I've never been
diagnosed as crazy unfortunately
I was willing to get married for nine
years I have a three men and I remember
being at Barneys
this will bring us up to Oh closer to as
I said yes with black Amex my name on it
the bills didn't go to me and I've never
said I love you for money and I couldn't
find one thing to buy so growing up we
didn't have any you couldn't have any
heroes we weren't I listen to music or
touch the television you know this is
Michigan you're in a suburb really all I
wanted to do is be a lady I read every
Miss Manners book I wanted to be a lady
I wanted to play the piano and I wanted
to run track
so kind of like a side note after I was
refused piano lessons but all three of
those boyfriends they all play the piano
and each one had one in their home and I
never once sat down and played it I
ended the relationship with Mark I gave
him back the ring it was a five carat
diamond people thought I was crazy
the only thing any of them like the many
of the men I've loved have had in common
is they've all pulled themselves up by
their bootstraps but I felt like for
some reason if I married him I'd be dead
in six months and I wasn't even a drug
addict yet nine months after Doug the
first panic attack and I was getting
them every day I met my second boyfriend
who was in a rock band and he was into a
20 20 50 year of being a cocaine addict
and an alcoholic and I had my first
drink with him by the third one I
stopped my heart stopped pounding and I
started drinking and I drank every day
for eight years so it was very bad
I have been written off for dad many
times and in the end I ended up with a
DUI my liver was shutting down
I passed the field test but I blew over
a point to and they took me straight to
the hospital and I guess quitting
drinking is one of the only things that
can kill you you can die from that and I
was at that point so I begged to check
from my ex-fiancee to see a foremost
from a psychiatrist and I don't I do not
know why our meeting went the way it did
but when I got to his office and I was
on very straight-laced buttoned up
he said sit anywhere maybe he didn't
like where I chose to sit but he's III
said you know I I can't seem to stop
drinking but if I do I'm very concerned
about having seizures what if anything
can you give me to prevent that he said
well first of all I think you need a
12-step program and secondly I think you
sexualized situations and you probably
always will
well even as I speak it I can hardly
believe it but it's everything it took
me decade and a half to convince myself
no one can tell that you were molested
Cassie yet you know it's just in your
head the two or three people I ever told
about it you know had close close
friends had convinced me of the same and
I was just starting to kind of move
forward in my life and kind of tore it
all that down but right now this
conversation it's either here or there
about two months later I finished
everything I needed to do for the DUI
mind you the classes were at 8:30 at
night and that was my morning except
going to the 15 days I've never even
heard of that place but I end up on a
mattress I went out every night for
eight years I wake up on a mattress on
the floor and it's three o'clock in the
morning the room is so dark I can't see
my hand in front of my face and there's
no alcohol in the house and I have the
DTS I'm shaking I'm sweating you know I
my mind knows it's not real but I can
feel and see the devil I say to this
other body next to me in the dark I
think I'm gonna have to go to the
hospital and they said well you're
walking and all of a sudden I heard this
voice in my ear it's in Cassie Cassie
just quit it was like that they were
speaking another language just quit like
I never heard those two words ever
before and this feeling of calm came
over me and I said since other human in
the darkness I think we were to go to
that eh-eh-eh-eh place tomorrow and they
said well you're going alone
I looked it up the next day and I went
and I took the brain desire and I said
yes some would say I'm an alcoholic
because in the beginning of the meeting
they asked are you an alcoholic and I
didn't respond but at the end they said
yes I am and I didn't drink again for
four years
I just think God wants me bad yeah I did
that that I decided to pick up a cocaine
addiction I'd been a cocaine addict
earlier in my life from one of the times
when my aunt needed money she sold me to
the guy across the hall and he was
probably in his first in his second
decade as a serious coke addict and I
remember somebody moving into the
complex who turned out to me his name
was Randy Randy turned out he was an
attorney that had been disbarred so he
became a commercial real estate way you
know and industrial law something like
that but somebody moved into the complex
who he whom he went to college with his
wife had just left him and I remember
him taking his first line of coke since
college six months later he's carpet
farming
he's in the carpet looking for pieces of
cocaine which I now know he was looking
for crack and I had Michael that first
boyfriend buy some cocaine for us and he
had never done cocaine we were getting
it every other day for the first three
months and I remember him looking up at
me after snorting a line off of a radio
of that Radiohead CD Pablo honey and
asking me do I look cool and I said
we're never doing coke again because I
remembered that guy crawling around on
the carpet I didn't want that kind of
blood on my hands but after recording
the drinking I had a long way back and I
was barely there when I got this pretty
big job and everyone thought I was gonna
fail at it around the same time a
neighbor asked me if I knew where to get
some cocaine and I called the friend and
found out who delivered and I decided to
get myself a ground
cocaine's anesthetic so I knew
everything that was happening but I felt
nothing and that's where I wanted
during that period of time the inside of
my nose fell out so I was snoring about
two grams a day which we're up to an
eight ball and for about a month I
couldn't even breathe I couldn't get
more coke up my nose until one day
something came out of my nose and it was
a chunk of cartilage basically this is
terrifying
I couldn't stop starting and my nose was
falling out a friend of mine a DJ and
visa went deaf and blind from his
cocaine use I didn't and also during the
entire time that I'm a coke addict I
continued to go to AAA meetings I go
late I leave early I sit in the back and
say nothing not one to accept that I'm
gonna be a cocaine cocaine addicts
always so I just felt so isolated so
alone and I got a serious sinus
infection and I called my gynecologist
because you know about my weight loss
and he flew back from San Francisco - I
was there for work to see a specialist
who never used the word cocaine but said
you need to stop the medication
immediately and remove the inside of my
nose okay I'm just gonna say it around
the time I met somebody and it was a
gated community in Calabasas I was help
he was recording an album he had a giant
bowl it's all these white chunks in it
and he said this isn't really a third
crack why did I say crack is a poor
man's drug this stuff I mean there's no
reason when you take the stuff you get
right and then you cook it and then you
only end up with half I'm telling you
he's moving a bomb Wow Oh God to say I
would have some help from some gentleman
friends and some but we'll just we'll
just stick to the straight and narrow on
this somebody introduced me to him in
the capacity of maybe we would hit it
off to it enjoying evening together
and I get to his home and he's in a
bathrobe he's got cash in one pocket
like Scarface had got in the other and
there's all these girls around with
really bad skin
there's contractors there that are doing
something and putting some early cues on
on his windows you know a lot happening
yeah I was a real crackheads rate now
because I'm a crackhead or alleged mmm
I'm sorry this is really uncomfortable
it's not like I live it by omission but
if you don't tell the truth if you don't
know where you stand you don't know
where you'll land right but this madam
if you will
says she this is the third person that I
ever met through her and she says oh you
know don't expect you know he's a party
person $100 $200 and we get there and he
asked me how much I said thousand and he
looks at me up and down he says okay
it has Hurley even closes the door and
then he says you're not really how are
you and I was so embarrassed I never
heard anybody like use that word like
speaking in that way
you know I mean like I said Hylian
myself you know I was in Moses are you
with me my best friend it's the
difference between hamburger meat and
filet mignon and he says prostitutions
prostitution
I guess I've come a long way that I can
even say that word
I this is an unmarried guy I mean I
carried on so much shame about that
that's a whole other story but that's
how I learned about crack
and it was but his first save unless
this isn't crack this is cocaine and I
cook it so it's cocaine
but isn't that crack but anyway we steal
it from the bong and he didn't have any
powder I could snort it took me about a
year before I started actually buying
crack I resent you for getting the acid
hey no one got me to say well I'm free
well I only had one cocaine dealer and
he said to me I can get you hard we
never use the word crack just hard
cocaine and I mean I guess in some ways
you could look at it like a blessing
because even if I finally stop snorting
cartilage still kept falling I still
kept coming out of my nose I I could put
a finger all the way in the back and it
would take a week for whatever it was to
come out Wow Wow
but
yeah so I started smoking crack and I
hid it from people intuitively I need to
hit it for it to hide it from people
around that time you know I had too much
money and too much grief pretty much
self-indulgent grief over some other
things so my dealer leaves a gram of
heroin over shows me how to smoke it
although he didn't smell good and you
know I'll be darned if I didn't it's
really not that easy when we first
started chasing the dragon if you will
to get it to roll up the tinfoil you
gotta kind of point the tinsel this way
I'm telling you it's kind of difficult
but I got the hang of it and just took
on another addiction so I was smoking
two grams of heroin a day
besides the crack and then I found that
bongs are not easy to transport one day
my regular dealer is out of town so we
send somebody over who comes with 30
packages all wrapped up the little
squares and I think is this what I'm
gonna become like what kind of drugs are
you on that you rob these things up in
little squares when I supposed to do
what's this I now know that's a dub but
that freaked me out so badly I called my
best friend I gave him a number of
somebody in AAA and said this is what's
been happening I need to check myself in
somewhere because I need two warrants
he'll want to quit and in six hours I
found myself in this bougie rehab
I'll say let's let's bring us to today
if I'm if I'm honest okay I i I've only
I smoked heroin
I didn't I do cocaine
oh the less a meeting I went to which is
a like seven years ago I took the brain
desire and said I know you gotta have 24
hours before you can share but it's been
five years so I'm just gonna say you
know I can't stop doing drugs and my
nose is falling out and my walking
closet that's where I would go to China
if someone was over - it was so loud
trying to blow my nose or get whatever
was in there out and um I think I'm
gonna die and I just left I think I did
say you people said the bar so low you
could trip over it
the last conversation I had with my
little sister she asked me how I wanted
to be buried she's never even seen me do
these drugs
I started and when I went I always
thought that if I ever ask for help that
it would be there that I've been paying
into that I never cried wolf and it's
kind of like seeing a fire extinguisher
every day and not only when you break
the glass you realize that it's empty
it's not even a real fire extinguisher
is like a book fire extinguisher and
when I was in had been an alcoholic I
sought out help for for that I'm looking
for a facility that they were quoting me
thirty thousand fifty thousand dollars
and no mind she was a little bit of a
different time and also you need
around-the-clock care so I didn't know
anything about someplace that was free
or or something of that nature
and I thought every rehab was that I
didn't I didn't know it was mostly
indigenous to just alcohol so I go to
this rehab it was a horrible experience
or one of the facilitators calling me in
her office and saying you know if you
want to dress like that every single day
you know that's fine but if you just
want to see it be seen as you know so
and that's you know just shallow and is
just good for nothing but being on
somebody's arm I mean that's fine that's
up to you you know just because we don't
have 600 thread-count sheets here
doesn't mean that we can't help you and
I am so I'm sitting there I'm so
exhausted
I didn't I this is what this woman is
saying to me you know
I mean I called him maybe the only favor
I ever had in my life to get this like
$32,000 to get to this place to realize
I'm the only one that paid any money and
they had these scholarships and they're
they're also charging my insurance ten
thousand dollars a month and she's
talking about thread count on sheets
come to find out that the guy Chris
Pathan was arrested three years later
for possession and insurance fraud
yeah I ended up losing two Mac computers
and my iPhone and my hard drive some
little boys who have been fooling around
with put a security pin on my phone so
the payment with couldn't be accepted
for my phone and I was there one day
prior to ninety so I lost the phone
number I had for 15 years I think I had
mentioned a little bit about having had
mentors our gentlemen that that helps
greatly financially in my life so the
loss of me not being able to call out my
phone not being able to call in yeah it
was of every proportions and after
basically I lost everything so after I
fled from that place where people were
so I gotta tell you people were pretty
thrilled now maybe cash he'll be off her
high horse I didn't know I was on such
high oars really and
couldn't find out my dealers been sent
away on a mandatory vacation jail of
course as soon as I got out the first
thing I wanted to do was used but I had
learned some stuff in rehab about cavy
and what words she used and possibly had
to go score which I had been ignorant of
I gave up my apartment to go to this
place thinking I needed a whole fresh
start so when I get out I ended up
staying with an old boyfriend but I go
down I start to travel down towards the
Skid Row area and I think I had like 150
bucks in my pocket I'm I'm going
emotional Western but I get to Alvarado
they look at me like I'm crazy
by the time I get down to on fifth and
Broadway you know I mean I think this is
just the most horrible place I thought
this is as far as I've ever been but now
I'm driving about like $60 because I'm
gonna give me some 110 bucks to show me
where he liked the dove is out of its
dub-dub you know and I see I meet this
guy
penny says you know I don't use drugs
anymore but you're going to eat alive
I'll show you where it is so it's a
follow your memory but he takes me down
to skid row
high score some drugs and which I think
I had money enough for a dime he waits
for me outside this tent that he allowed
that he is rented for me so I could
smoke my heroin and gets on the bus with
me and he he's an african-american man
I've never dated a black man before I
really had any experience of that but he
pulled some money out of his pocket and
says oh I'm for real can I give can we
try to get your phone number and it's
kind of awkward and kind of gauche but
also boyish and sweet and I look at him
and I think
man you know I really don't want to get
that so Terry check for this one
I think he's must be like 26 years old
come to find out he was much older but
um I said I would take his number and
consider it well it was on a Kraken you
know so I started smoking crack and aha
and smoking heroin and now I'm not in my
own place anymore the delivery guy isn't
there you know the left hand till he
knows what the right hand is doing
long story short Andrew comes back to
catch me in bed with another man with me
and Andrew rather than whoa that sounded
so much less embarrassing in my head ah
[Music]
mind you we were not
boyfriend/girlfriend but I do think
there's really that goes against this
manners for sure and that it really is
not and it's not really a good thing
Cody that's a bad yeah not good not good
so I ended up calling this person that I
met and he comes and rescues me
and I starts I'm staying at a hotel like
not quite a crack hotel but like a
really crappy hotel now I mean I used to
stay at the Bristol in Paris right
this is it this is for reference come on
yeah yeah yeah that was a billion mile
fall people have been waiting for this
billion mile fall I ended up following
him down here and I was in the first
week of being down here he gave me a
black eye almost knocked me out cold
I started a plane and thought I'd went
through the roof it was 9:00 in the
morning and what hurt the most was I was
smiling at him he said he thought I was
laughing at him he had been silver when
I met him but I quickly started smoking
crack with me so I found a place to hide
out and I thought I was trying to decide
if I wanted to live or die and it's kind
of been in charge introduction time ever
since I fell in barracks was the whole
thing and I felt like he was the last
place anyone would ever look for me
and I thought I could fix it by myself
and I am there with this
people always say god never gives you
more than anything you can hand alright
I think you're saying so the only thing
to my understanding the crux of the
Bible is free will
it's my thing gonna Ecuador but in any
language on any planet in any vampire
story a vampire could not enter unless
they ask permission so that's the front
in the back of the matter the only thing
that I've figured out from these last
its I have been I saw this over two and
a half years ago
if I lied about it I apologize I mean
I've done things since then this is also
embarrassing but the only thing I've
learned is that manners are the most
important thing to me and also that I
really didn't need to learn this lesson
[Music]
thank you very much for sharing this
amazing story I'd love to have you back
again we'll do it again because I think
there's a lot more yes this is this
would be part one okay you're ready you
come on back okay thank you thank you
you